LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
Louis Gray here from
the Moscone
Center at San Francisco.
I've got Chris Lyon, hardware
engineer on the Chromebook
Pixel here with me,
as well as Andrew
Bowers, director of product.
So I'm really excited to have
you guys both onstage.
Thanks for joining me again.
CHRIS LYON: Thank you.
ANDREW BOWERS: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, the Chromebook
Pixel, it's just
been one of the best devices
I've ever had.
Just straight out.
Chrome OS has really been
something that's really
intriguing to me for
a long time.
We've really enjoyed having
the ability to have all my
content in one place.
And you can switch from computer
to computer, and it
follows you.
But for the first time ever,
this is a device that was
completely designed in
hardware by Google.
So I wanted to talk to
you guys about that.
And talk me through that
process, in terms of how did
that happen?
And what were we trying
to achieve?
ANDREW BOWERS: Yeah.
So the first thing we were
trying to do is really just
create the best Chromebook
possible, no holds barred, and
really thinking about someone
who's using a Chromebook all
day long as well.
So a lot of focus, attention
to detail, on
how the device feels.
We really want the hardware
to disappear.
We want to make it feel like an
immersive movie, where you
forget that you're in a movie
theater and you're just really
focused on what you're doing.
And so part of that's making
that hardware disappear so you
don't feel the keyboard, the
trackpad, things like that.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, what are the
kind of attributes in hardware
that you were trying
to get to?
How did you decide whether it
had an 11-inch screen or a
15-inch screen?
What were the things where you
made a decision on that?
How do you go about deciding?
CHRIS LYON: So for those items,
when we were setting
out in the early design process,
we did a large number
of user studies on various
screen sizes, various
configurations, keyboard
placement, et cetera.
And a lot of those various
parameters all fit together to
give us the proper shape
of the laptop.
One of the early goals was
we definitely wanted an
absolutely full metal
enclosure.
It feels very nice hold,
really solid design.
But that comes with a lot of
additional challenges as to
how you fit all of the
other components
together inside the system.
LOUIS GRAY: OK.
And so when I look at this,
having tried the previous
Chromebook models that were
plastic, they'd come out.
They were very light.
This one has a stronger feel.
It's kind of more industrial.
And one of the things that's
happened as a result of
making, I guess, the ultimate
Chromebook is it's a little
bit more expensive than the
original Chromebook.
We've been looking at.
Samsung.
I've got three of those
at my house.
Got one for my wife.
Got one for myself.
Got two for my parents.
And they're all $249.
And obviously, the Pixel
is a different beast.
It's starting at, I think,
$1,249, and you basically got
a little bit more expensive.
So what was the thought
behind that?
Was that something where we
wanted to set it up kind of as
a reference model?
Or do we expect these to
be for the mass market?
CHRIS LYON: So Pixel should be
thought of as a halo device,
something where we really want
to showcase a large number of
new technologies that aren't
necessarily in the other
Chromebooks, but things that
we want developers to
experiment with--
things like the high pixel
density touchscreen, things
like keyboard backlight.
I'm not sure if you're
aware, but there's a
microphone array in here.
There's two up top
for beam forming.
There's noise cancellation.
There's the LTE.
This is the first Chromebook
with that.
And again, these are a number of
features where the hardware
has to lead the software
a bit.
We have to get the features out
there, build a critical
mass of users, and then
encourage the developers to
target those features.
LOUIS GRAY: You mentioned
the high screen density.
One thing about the Pixel is
that you shouldn't have to
ever see a pixel.
I mean, that's sort of what
we've been talking about.
You say Chrome.
You want to get the Chrome out
of the way, the browser, and
really have the user be directly
interfacing with
their data, with
their content.
I'm glad you mentioned LTE.
I'm actually on LTE right now.
The Wi-Fi at the conference has
been really exceptional.
It goes up.
It goes down.
There's a lot of people fighting
for attention, and
I've really cut through all
of that by getting on LTE.
And having it on this type of
a device has really been
exceptional.
And so when I look at the Pixel
specifically, there's
really those three things
that have set it apart--
the inclusion of the LTE, the
high density pixel screen, and
the touch aspect of it.
Now, touch is something you
traditionally accept with a
tablet or a mobile phone.
What was the thought process
behind having a touchscreen?
And how are we seeing users
behave with the touchscreen,
or possibly developers
coding for it?
ANDREW BOWERS: So I think that
you hit on it right there,
which is touchscreens
are becoming
pervasive in our lives.
So they're on your phone.
They're on tablets.
They're even on ATMs and
the gas station pumps.
And so if you look at children
interacting with a laptop,
they've probably used their
parents' phone or their
tablet, and so they're touching
the screen already.
And so it's just a very
intuitive way versus an
indirect on a trackpad
or a mouse.
And so we're seeing it become
more and more pervasive, and
we think of it as yet
another way to
interact with the computer.
It's not the only way you
interact with a laptop, but
it's another way.
So to give you an example, on
Tuesday I spent five hours on
a plane, a cramped seat.
But I could hold my Pixel like
this, and I could scroll and
archive email on the plane
much more easily.
LOUIS GRAY: The viewers at home
can't see your hands.
ANDREW BOWERS: That's
a good point.
So a lot of times, you'll find
you'll use something in a
different way.
Like for instance, when you're
cramped in on plane, using it
like this rather than having
to use the trackpad.
So it opens up new
opportunities.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Absolutely.
And I've seen that a lot.
There's one really cool thing
that you get the right screen
combination, you can rotate the
entire screen 90 degrees
or 180 degrees to be fixed.
And literally, you look at the
Chromebook right side up, even
if it's on its side, which
is kind of entertaining.
And so for a lot of people who
have like a vertical monitor,
I can see them possibly
extending out and having that
vertical monitor.
And the processor in here is
strong enough that they can
push all those pixels even in
that new configuration.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the speed.
This is obviously faster.
It's faster.
It's brighter.
It's got a lot of attributes
to it.
So what about the speed?
How did that come into play?
CHRIS LYON: So we designed the
Pixel to be Chrome fast.
The idea here was hardware
should not get in the way of
the experience.
We wanted this to be able to
show off the browser and the
operating system as
well as possible.
This is an Intel
i5 CPU in here.
There's four gigabytes of RAM,
pretty standard other features
internally aside from that.
But it's more than
enough for web
applications, for HTML5 games.
And it should actually enable a
significant amount of future
development coming there.
One of the things we're really
excited about is HTML5 games
are becoming more and
more popular.
And actually, we're seeing
developers make use of the
touchscreen, of the
high PPI display.
And we're really hoping that
as we can build more of a
critical mass of systems out
there with those features that
people will be implementing
more and more higher end
applications.
So we really wanted to make
sure that it had the
horsepower under the
hood there to be
able to handle that.
ANDREW BOWERS: And just to
add to that real quick.
I think one of the ways we also
think about is not we
don't want consumers to have to
think about what processor
do they have in the machine.
We just want it to be, is
it fast enough for what
I want it to do?
And so we want to get
to that world too.
LOUIS GRAY: And one of things
that I've experienced having
the touchscreen on the laptop
is you can have more of an
immersive experience, be
it with Maps or Photos.
There's something really
breathtaking about diving into
Google Maps or the Google+
Photos experience and just
being able to pinch to zoom
and getting right
into what you want.
And you just swipe to the side
and have it go away.
And it's something that's
really become natural.
It's one of those funny things
about having a glossy screen
that you touch all the time.
I was in the car the other day
making a quick web change--
I was on LTE-- and I
saw my fingerprints
all over the screen.
How do you guys handle just
managing that type of thing,
where you get a little bit dirty
and you clean it off?
So what do you think about
that kind of stuff?
ANDREW BOWERS: It's
called a cloth.
CHRIS LYON: It is actually a big
engineering challenge, and
it is something that we
put a fair amount of
work into with Pixel.
Obviously, there's still a
long ways to go in that
direction, and it's something
we're continuing to research.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, it's one
of those fun things.
And you don't realize how often
you touch it until you
get the little bit of glare, and
you're like wow, I touch
this thing all the time.
You've got the hands on there.
CHRIS LYON: One of the nice
things though-- the screen is
Gorilla Glass coating,
just very resilient.
So at least even if you are
smudging it, you don't have to
worry about damaging it.
LOUIS GRAY: What I find is I
often am reaching to other
people's computers and expecting
that I can impact
the touchscreen.
And I'm like, are
you kidding me?
Why are you using
that product?
CHRIS LYON: Actually, that's
been an interesting problem in
the office.
So when we were using these
initially internally a lot,
people got in the habit of when
they'd written an email
then just pushing the Send or
the Compose button on there.
And you'd see people walking
around when this was still
secret and we couldn't have
them in every meeting.
And they'd have their ThinkPad
out, and they'd push the
screen, and they'd get mad.
LOUIS GRAY: Nothing
would happen.
CHRIS LYON: Definitely a number
of our vendors and
partners probably caught
on to that.
LOUIS GRAY: We have like five
minutes left, so I want to
talk a little about Chrome OS.
Now, you know Chrome OS is still
a little bit new for a
lot of people, and it's really
kind of growing in maturity in
terms of the capability.
Every time Chrome gets better,
Chrome OS gets better.
And about two years ago-- maybe
it was even three at
this point-- with the Cr-48
model coming out, really kind
of the first reference
point of having a
Chrome device out there.
It wasn't super fast.
There were some aspects of the
hardware which were not
perfect, but it was a
fun reference point.
And since then, we've continued
to see iterations
from Chrome via devices from
Samsung, Lenovo, HP, Acer.
I hope I've mentioned
them all.
And you've seen people come up
with different price points
and different sizes.
Now, what has been your kind of
response to see how Chrome
OS is evolving?
And what is left?
What is kind of the last things
that the Chrome OS
should be doing, where people
can really safely leave more
traditional operating systems?
ANDREW BOWERS: So the Samsung
Chromebook has been the number
one laptop on Amazon for about
190 days since its launch,
consecutively.
And so I think that speaks for
itself in terms of what people
are ready for.
With the Pixel, we've taken it
a step further as well in
terms of there are a lot of
people that wanted high-end
hardware, precision hardware.
They spend 10 hours a
day on a Chromebook.
And so when we say for everyone,
we don't just mean
people that want a very
affordable laptop, but also a
precision experience with a
great keyboard and trackpad
and touchscreen.
And so with the Pixel, we're
bringing that as well.
So you cover different
needs out there
for different people.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
And I think you're mentioning
that you say for everyone, but
it's also for everything.
As someone who's very Google
Drive-centric, with all of my
files and my applications there,
going to Gmail, going
to my Google+, I really believe
at this point every
computer is my computer.
So long as I can get
to my Google
content, it's all there.
But actually, I'd much rather
be using a Pixel.
If you handed me a ThinkPad,
I'd be fine.
I'd be able to boot up Chrome
and do all my work.
But with the Pixel, it just
has such kind of a
professional, high quality
experience.
You don't want to suffer the
screen display of something
else which isn't as strong.
And even just the little bits
with like the keys and the
hardware and the trackpad are
so professionally designed.
And so I think you can really
see that, for those people who
do get an opportunity to
get their hands on it
to check that out.
So for the many people who are
watching on the livestream,
how do they get their
hands on a Pixel?
ANDREW BOWERS: So they can go
to the Google Play store
online or bestbuy.com as well.
LOUIS GRAY: And Best Buy
has them in display.
I remember that's actually
where I bought the three
Samsung Chromebooks
that I got.
I almost cleaned them out.
And I think I sold five other
ones in the 10 minutes I was
there just playing demo.
And so I think it's great that
you have the Pixels out there
getting really big
distribution.
Anything else that the viewers
should know about the Pixel
before we cut?
ANDREW BOWERS: I think that you
really have to experience
it to understand what it
is and what it means.
And I think it brings
Chromebooks to a whole other
level of user that want
to use Chromebooks.
And so we hope that it'll open
up a lot of opportunities for
people to experience Chromebooks
and how easy they
are to use and how great it
is to live with them.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, thank you
very much, both for you
joining me on stage and for
all the work that you did
putting into this product.
It's obviously something I use
every single day, not just at
the conference.
And I constantly run into
my kids saying, hey,
Daddy, look at that.
And they'll click on my
touchscreen and accidentally
click on an ad or something.
But they understand exactly
how to interface with a
touchscreen, because they've
been growing up with tablets.
And we're seeing really the next
generation of personal
computing happen right
in front of us.
So thank you very
much for that.
CHRIS LYON: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: So for all of you
watching on this livestream,
appreciate you joining us.
We're going to kick you
back to the sessions.
I believe up next we have
an event with Android.
You won't want to miss Reto
Meier talking with Hugo Barra
and Hiroshi Lockheimer.